so call it The Return of the King or
Return of the Jedi or both but Conan
O'Brien's new show titled Conan
premiered on TV as last Monday marking
his return to television since NBC was
like oh yeah all right well he's not
gonna move this Tonight Show to midnight
you know it was just really funny yeah
funny-looking exactly we didn't really
think of something really good cuz I'm
alive ideas and this isn't helping me oh
dude I got an idea I can raise you for
you for us just bear with me though hey
try to put try to put your own head like
in your ass that's in my own head in my
I don't know if I'm Tanya this is my
brainstorm that is that is what helps me
out every time yeah but like why would I
do that
but last time I did that last time I put
my own head in my ass so one word dude
Joey Isis
I'm telling you it works all right yeah
do it all right yeah just over under
let's try it over under it's crazy
Oh can't you look like a roly-poly
mmm-hmm
I tell you dude act is official having
your head in your ass is like the best
thing ever all right I'm gonna make a
phone call and get this his show Conan
snagged four point 15 million viewers
that's more than Letterman and Leno act
is awesome and yeah the viewers fur is
for a show are probably a little higher
cuz it's the first show is the premiere
everyone needs to see it and whatnot and
I've actually heard people griping about
how his show feels like it's just old
Conan
are you serious him not being old-school
Conan's what cost him viewers when he
switched to the Tonight Show when he was
on Late Night with Conan O'Brien he had
his own brand of comedy it was different
than Jay Leno Letterman although many
switches to the Tonight Show whose
audience was different than his audience
and he has to edit himself just ever so
slightly he was kind of like Conan light
so the
Leno viewers didn't want to watch this
new guy in the Conan O'Brien viewers
didn't want to watch Conan light which
goes to show you when you try to please
everybody that means you're pleasing
nobody
so NBC being well dip shits but their
heads firmly placed up the rectal cavity
said it's a fire fire Cronin Cronin
LaRon final corner is about the onion
fire Conan all right yeah good getting a
job and this is town anymore going in so
the point of this video is to well one
call NBC [ __ ] NBC you gave heroes
four years
to season two was the best and you gave
arguably the funniest guy in late-night
seven to eight months this goes to show
you when you get up here
you lose brain cells and the second
point of this video is to illustrate if
Conan seems like old Conan O'Brien
that's not a bad thing the guy's a
comedic genius just let him work griping
about that it's like a 40 year old guy
saying oh man my 40 year old wife just
got a makeover she looks like she did
when she was 20 like in her prime is
stupid now we don't know if he'll keep
four point fifteen million viewers for
too long I mean like I said first shows
were huge everyone needs to see him if
he keeps about two million viewers I
think he'll be sitting good but him
being on top like that at least even for
one show sends a clear message to NBC
and that message is do you s clickin
person what do you say what did you say
you heard me so have you seen Conan's
new show and if you did what you think
about it comment below just blow that
[ __ ] up and if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more than click
right here to see more
[Music]